[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halallweg willkommen an diesem
Sonntagabend alles zum Fußball hat
nachher svenn Foss schönen guten Abend
schauen wir auf die Themen von
heute Todeszone so nennt die WHO das
alschifer Krankenhaus in Gaza
Mitarbeiter der Organisation sind erschü
über die Verhältnisse im
Gebäude wie das 60 Milliarden Loch
stopfen der Finanzminister will jetzt
wirtschaftubventionen kürzen und in der
Ampel knirscht mal wieder und gepatzt
gegen die Türkei das deutsche
Nationalteam verliert sein Testspiel in
Berlin Trainer nagelsmann warnt aber vor
Schwarzmalerei es ist ein Stück Hoffnung
im Krieg nach Meldungen aus Katar und
den USA steht eine Vereinbarung über
eine Feuerpause und die Freilassung
israelischer Geiseln kurz bevor doch
noch gehen die Angriffe weiter
Mitarbeiter der WHO berichten von
schlimmen Zuständen in der größten
Klinik des Gazastreifens noch immer sein
etwa 300 Patienten im alschifer
Krankenhaus die israelische Armee war in
den Klinikkomplex vorgedrungen und
vermutet darunter eine Kommandozentrale
der Hamas Dominik
lmeister eine Stunde konnte die
das alschiefer Krankenhaus besuchen es
sei eine Todeszone man hätte auch ein
Massengrab gesehen 80 Menschen sollen
darin begraben sein Anerkennung für das
krankenhausteam das ist ein Albtraum für
sie aber wie Sie wissen ist das alles
komplex aber wir werden unser Bestes
geben die verbliebenen Patienten will
man so schnell wie möglich herausbringen
31 Säuglinge konnte die WHO inzwischen
evakuieren sie wurden nach hafah in den
Süden gebracht Israel veröffentlicht
Abend neue Bilder eines 55 m langen
Tunnels der Hamas 10 m unter dem
alschifer Krankenhaus wofür genau
genutzt wurde noch unklar den
Militäreinsatz im Gazastreifen will die
Armee ausweiten um weitere
hamasterroristen aufzuspüren am
Wochenende waren nach Krankenhausangaben
in der Stadt hananunis mindestens 47
Menschen getötet worden unabhängig
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht
innenpolitisch steigt der Druck auf
Israels Regierung mehr zu tun damit die
über 230 Geiseln der Hamas freikommen
Qatar kommt dabei eine Schlüsselrolle zu
der Ministerpräsident des Emirates gibt
sich bei einem Treffen mit dem EU
außenbeauftragten Borell
optimistisch ich bin jetzt
zuversichtlicher dass wir nahe genug
sind um eine Einigung zu erziehen die
die Menschen sicher nach Hause
zurückbringen
kann immer mehr Palästinenser sind
innerhalb des Gazastreifens auf der der
Flucht die humanitäre Lage
verschlechtert sich viele kommen nur
notdürftig unter wie in diesen Zelten in
chunis hinzu kommt seit heute noch Regen
und
Sturm fragen wir Michael bewerunge in
telaviv was ist dran an den Meldungen
über einen Deal Feuerpausen gegen
Freilassung der
Geiseln also seit Tagen gibt es immer
wieder Berichte dass ein geiseldeal
angeblich kurz bevorstünde der Inhalt
immer ähnlich 50 bis 100 Geiseln sollen
gegen palästinensische Gefangene in
israelischen Gefängnissen ausgetauscht
werden als Gegenleistung soll es eine
fünftägige Waffenruhe geben das Problem
dabei ist es gibt diesen Deal bislang
noch nicht und es ist doch nichts
darüber bekannt wann er denn tatsächlich
kommen sollte premier Netanyahu hat es
dementiert solche Berichte auch aus
Washington gibt es dementies von
entsprechenden berichten die die
Washington Post lanciert hatte
wie es weitergeht ist unklar der Druck
auf beide Seiten steigt jedenfalls
sowohl auf die Hamas der militärische
Druck als auch auf die israelische
Regierung innenpolitisch und das Thema
Waffenruhe ist dabei anscheinend der
Kern des Streits es gibt einen Teil im
kriegskabinett die sagen wir können der
Heras keine fünftägige Waffenruhe
gewähren weil in dieser Zeit könnte sie
sich sehr effektiv reorganisieren ein
anderer Teil sagt wir müssen endlich
auch dem Druck der Angehörigen der
Geiseln nachgeben vielleicht haben wir
nur jetzt eine Chance einen geiseldeal
zu vereinbaren lasst uns jetzt so viele
Geisen wie möglich nach Hause holen auch
wenn es dafür ein Zugeständnis
militärischer Art gibt die Einschätzung
von Michael bwerung live aus Tel Aviv
vielen
Dank die vom Iran unterstützten hui
Rebellen haben vor der Küste Jemens ein
Frachtschiff entführt und mehrere
Geiseln genommen das mit Autos beladene
Schiff gehört offenbar anteilich einem
britischisraelischen Geschäftsmann in
einer Mitteilung der husis heißt es alle
Schiffe mit Verbindungen zum
israelischen Feind sein legitime
Ziele am Volkstrauertag heute wird
traditionell der Opfer von Krieg und
Gewaltherrschaft gedacht Bundespräsident
Steinmeier und kronprinzessin Victoria
von Schweden die derzeit Deutschland
besucht legten in der gedenkstätdte neue
Wache in berlingrenze nieder bei der
anschließenden Gedenkstunde im Bundes t
mahnte die Kronprinzessin wir dürfen
niemals die Lehren aus den Schrecken von
Krieg und Tyrannei
vergessen Finanzminister Lindner macht
SPD und Grüne dafür verantwortlich dass
die Mehrwertsteuer in der Gastronomie
zum Jahresende wieder auf 19% steigen
soll das hätte nicht sein müssen sagte
der FDP Politiker der Bild am Sonntag
nach dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts Fehlen der
Koalition 60 Milliarden Euro im Haushalt
Lindner will bei der
Wirtschaftsförderung sparen Frank
Buchwald sparen aber wo der
Finanzminister wagt sich aus der Deckung
kurzfristig seien die Folgen des
Karlsruher Urteils zwar hart so Lindner
im Zeitungsinterview langfristig aber
könne Deutschland sich Chancen
erarbeiten wir werden jetzt gezwungen
mit weniger öffentlichen Subventionen
die Wirtschaft zu modernisieren es geht
jetzt um weniger Bürokratie agilere
Verwaltung technikfreundlichkeit und die
Mobilisierung privaten Kapitals für
Investitionen weniger Subventionen das
trifft vor allem das grüngeführte
Wirtschaftsministerium allein die
Energiewende ein milliardenprjekt die
Vorsitzende der Grünen im Berlin
direktinterview wenig
begeistertoll nicht entscheiden dass
Arbeitsplätze zwar geschaffen werden
aber außerhalb von Deutschland
geschaffen werden und wir sollten vor
allem gucken dass unsere Finanzpolitik
nicht am Ende zu einer innovationsbremse
und damit auch zu einer
wettbewerbsfähigkeitsbremse wird auch
beim Koalitionspartner SPD sehen Sie
Lindners Vorschlag kritisch die
Sozialdemokraten setzen eher auf mehr
Einnahmen wenn die Einnahmenseite
adressiert ist reden wir auch gerne
darüber wie wir die verbessern können
beispielsweise indem wir die
vermögensten 5% vermögensten diesem Land
stärker zur Krisenbewältigung
heranziehen können keine gute Idee
findet die Opposition statt Hörer
Steuern mehr Menschen in Arbeit bringen
so empfiehlt es die
Union wir haben 4 Millionen Erwerb
fähige Menschen im Bürgergeld wir
müssten versuchen wenigstens einen Teil
davon jetzt mal in Beschäftigung zu
bringen da krieg die Ampel gar nichts
geregelt klingt nach zof vor allem
innerhalb der Koalition dabei hat die
verteilungsdiskussion noch gar nicht
richtig
angefangen das ganze Interview mit
grünen Chefin Ricarda lang können Sie in
Berlin direkt sehen gleich nach uns in
Argentinien findet heute die Stichwahl
um das Präsidentenamt statt erwartet
wird ein Kopf an Kopf Rennen zur Wahl
stehen Wirtschaftsminister Sergio Massa
sowie der ultrarechte Ökonom Javier m
der politneuling will den Staat radikal
umbauen das Land befindet sich in einer
schweren Wirtschaftskrise die
Inflationsrate liegt bei rund
140% fast die Hälfte der Menschen lebt
in
Armut und jetzt zum Fußball wenn der
leichte Aufwärtstrend der deutschen
Mannschaft ist seit gestern wieder
vorbei ja die 2:3eder Lage gegen die
Türkei war auf jeden Fall ein Rückschlag
für das deutsche Team auf dem Weg zur
heimem im kommenden Jahr im
ausverkauften Berliner Olympia Stadion
ließ das Team um Kapitän gündoan vor
allem Stabilität
vermissen zumindest am Tag danach haben
die Spieler für gute Stimmung sorgen
können bei einem Fanfest neben dem
Stadion die torparty gestern fand aber
nur in rotstadt die türkischen Anhänger
akustisch klar überlegen vor allem il GÜ
wurde B vor und während des Spiels gegen
das Heimatland seine Eltern lautstark
ausgepfiffen vor 72 000 zu viele
Defizite in der Defensive die längst
noch nicht turniertauglich ist doch der
Bundestrainer whrt sich gegen Kritik an
der Taktik wir können jetzt wieder
anfangen alles schwarz zu malen und
alles schlecht zu sehen das ist können
wir machen wer wir nicht weiterkommen
als Fußballnation gegen Österreich wird
es einige personelle Wechsel geben doch
das wichtigste Ziel für das Spiel in
Wien ist sie wollen erstmals unter
nagelsmann kein Gegentor
kassieren wie die Polizei mitteilte kam
es gestern zu Ausschreitungen rund um
das Länderspiel 92 Personen wurden
festgenommen außerdem wurden 71
Strafermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet
mehrere Menschen wurden verletzt
Magdeburg ist neuer Tabellenführer der
handballbundesliga nach einem deutlichen
38 z31 Sieg gegen Eisen Naach und der
Niederlage des bisherigen Spitzenreiters
die Füchse Berlin verloren nämlich beim
TV Kiel mit 26 Z 30 schon zur Pause
lagen die Kieler mit vier Treffern vorn
der deutsche Rekordmeister bleibt auf
Platz 5 in der
Tabelle drei Rennen drei Siege für
bobpilot Johannes Lochner beim Weltcup
Auftakt auf der Olympiabahn von Peking
gewann der 33-Jährige noch einmal im
Vierer Bob Rekordweltmeister Francesco
friedrich wurde mit seiner Crew nur
Dritter das war's vom Sport ja wollo ja
wollo danke schön fehlt noch der Blick
aufs Wetter morgen zeigt sich südlich
der Donau häufiger die Sonne sonst
bleibt es eher trüb mit Regen die
Höchstwerte liegen zwischen 9 und 12°
dazu weht der Wind an den Küsten
stürmisch um Ost :4 Uhr begrüßt Sie
Christian sieers im heutejournal wir
sagen danke und tschüss wünschen Ihnen
einen guten Start in die neue Woche und
schauen jetzt gespannt auf Berlin direkt
unter Kunter